I'm honored
speak at the inauguration of
solovey as president of Yale this is a
big historic Eve
and what I want to do is to try to focus
this event on some of the enduring
values at Yale what defines this
institution really I've been teaching at
Yale for 30 years and I've been teaching
undergraduate finance at Yale for 25
years all this experience has led me to
kind of think about the values that we
were promoting like my teaching course
called financial markets which you are
all welcome to take because it's online
as part of open Yale also Yale has
joined with Coursera and they were going
to be producing courses that are more
like real classroom courses in the sense
that there would be a schedule and exams
and problem sets and so I'm going to be
teaching financial markets in the
starting January of 2014 but I won't be
there it'll be recordings of me but I'll
be in charge I think this experience
fits in very well with president
salaries emphasis on a more accessable
Yale and improve communications so I'm
happy to be involved in these kinds of
teaching activities and I expect to see
them grow in importance in in the future
but as I I guess has I mature and have
been taught for many years and I start
I've been increasingly wondering about
our values that underlie what I teach a
nice
what others here teaches well so I've
been preparing
I've prepared thousands of people I
think it's thousands - for a life in
finance
after this financial crisis there has
been a lot of anger toward the financial
community and it's made me think more
about what I've been doing all these
years there's an impulse when you teach
a finance course to say I'm going to
show you the ropes and I'll tell you how
to get ahead but after a financial
crisis when many people have been saying
I think these people should be in jail
I started thinking have I done the right
thing our society is getting
increasingly unequal and I have been
involved in I think my students are
successful generally going into finance
has been a income optimising event but
you know I didn't come to Yale to do
that sort of thing in fact what one
thing that originally attracted me to
you was the intellectual spirit here I
which I thought was I thought was
different and I I wanted to say
something about that let me come back to
that I have a lot of complex ideas that
are coming into my head on the occasion
of this inauguration
I thought the title of my talk is
finance and the good Society which is a
book I actually wrote this for the
revised version of my
course I first taught financial markets
online in 2008 and then the financial
crisis hit in the spring of 2008 so it's
just before the real crisis and then I
thought you know I look back in what I'd
done and I thought maybe I haven't
really conveyed the most important thing
so I asked to have my course redone and
then I wrote a book to go with the
course called finance and the goods
society so what does that mean
I like the term goods society I know
that it can't be translated into any
other language because I get complaints
from the translators of my book if you
try to translate that into German for
example Goethe gesellschaft it comes out
like the good Society one finds in a
beer Keller doesn't sound right I think
the term good society goes back to the
19th century and it used to mean or just
nice people you know people who take
good care of their children and hygiene
and education and good citizens but in
the 20th century the word good society
took on new meanings or more in in the
English language in particular there was
a book in 1936 written by walter
Lippmann who was a prominent social
philosopher of the time the title of the
book was the good Society
and he said what is the essence of what
he calls the good society and he said
it's really the Golden Rule do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you
I'm approximately quoting Jesus which
seems appropriate in the present
surroundings in Matthew 7:12 he said so
in everything do to others what you
would have them do to you for this sums
up the law and the prophets so that's
the golden rule but you know it when you
read this carefully I'm not a biblical
scholar but I'm reading it carefully at
the moment he says this sums up the law
and the
so what he's really saying is that this
isn't an original new idea this is an
old idea and in fact you can find quotes
in the Old Testament that seemed to say
much the same thing walter Lippmann was
Jewish so it's it's he hastened to point
out that it's not just a Christian
tradition it goes to all the religions I
can quote Jesus a little bit more which
is relevant at the moment you've know
these quotes love your neighbor as
yourself if you want to be perfect go
sell your possessions and give to the
poor and you will have treasure in
heaven I'm thinking about these things
because they seem inconsistent with
finance or they may seem inconsistent
with finance because finance is all
about keeping secrets
making exclusive deals trading against
someone else hoping to get an advantage
you buy low and sell high
that means buy from someone who
unwittingly doesn't know that he's
selling it to you for too little and
selling it for too much to someone else
that doesn't sound like the golden rule
does it but I'm what Lippmann thought is
that the golden rule is really something
that people discover individually I
think it has something to do with what
Peter Salovey called emotional
intelligence that's something that Peter
salary our new president has been a
pioneer on there's different kinds of
human intelligence some people are very
good at math but they may be very poor
at judging other people there's a
different kind of intelligence which is
the intelligence of judging people
empathizing with others and
incorporating it into your your
fundamental actions I like to think
that's something that we teach here yeah
I guess you you can teach intelligence
to some extent but I think what walter
Lippmann was saying is that people who
have developed a emotional intelligence
realize that we share our lives with
other people and there's really it's we
really don't want to be selfish in in
the sense of the word that seems to
apply to some aggressive financial
dealings I just want to mention since
I'm quoting Jesus so much that it's not
just the Christian religion that
embodies the golden rule well they might
have a different name for it
Tim or Quran is an economist who wrote a
nice book recently about economics and
Islam and when we think of the Islam
religion we think of maybe it's a lot of
arbitrary restrictions for example on
business that they can't charge interest
but in fact the Islamic religion has as
well quoting Quran a major emphasis on
generosity as a vehicle for solving
social problems so they might not say
the Golden Rule but it's the same idea
in the Jewish tradition there is a
concern against trading against superior
information often quoted is the
Leviticus passage do not curse the death
or put a stumbling block in front of the
blind this is called the before the
blind principle in Jewish law so I think
that there's something that we can teach
in our in a Yale or in a university
environment which which can soften
finance and make it to something more
relevant and important for our times
Tony Crone man was Dean of the Yale Law
School
and he wrote a book a few years ago
called education and why our
universities have given up on the
meaning of life
and he makes the point quite I recommend
this book it's quite a passionate plea
for education of a more traditional
sense the people used to go to college
to discover what it all means but now
the universities are so
compartmentalized and divided and so
filled with research scholars who who
made their reputation in in advancing
the frontier in one field that they
don't seem to offer answers to those
questions now of course you can read
Kremlin's book cynically and say you
know what does he want anyway you know a
lot of our bright young students are not
really looking for someone to hold their
hand and tell them what it all means
because they wouldn't believe it for a
minute and they preach they want to
learn real real things but I think there
is something underlying spirit and
motivation that that we do and we do
value when we do recognize and people I
was thinking why I came to Yale
originally I think it was certain people
that impressed me a great deal here and
I think they impressed me for their
genuineness or the reality James Tobin
was an economist here at Yale who died
about 10 years ago I actually
interviewed in him just before he died
and wrote an article about him but what
was it that I admired in him I think
ultimately it was his his moral purpose
that is that he thought things were
interesting that other people might not
and I like that what it kind of meant is
that he was more of a generalist
polymath but that's something else that
I think I admire you
get too focused on one discipline so
that that's why again referring back to
Saliva's emphasis on communication I
think that the more we communicate with
each other across departmental lines the
better off we are
I might also add that one of James
Tobin's students here at Yale was Janet
Yellen who got her PhD in economics here
and I suppose you may have heard that
President Obama nominated her to replace
Ben Bernanke as the next chairman of the
Federal Reserve well I know Janet well
and I have the same feeling about her
that I had about Tobin that she's
ultimately a moral person I can tell I
know what I think motivates her she is
not taking this position I can tell you
for certainty she's not taking this
position salivating at the job offer
she'll get when she gets out and that
would be a typical view by some cynical
people and I I think that we really need
in a Federal Reserve Chairman is not
just some high-powered mathematical
economist but we need someone who can
judge politics and who appreciates the
kind of suffering that various people
are going on people ask whether Janet is
a hawk or a dove I keep getting asked by
reporters on this a hawk is supposedly
someone who wants to be tough on
monetary policy and keep inflation down
but a dove is someone who's worried
about the unemployed and wants to
doesn't care about inflation so she's
being criticized now as to dovish but I
personally think that she is pained by
the suffering of other people but knows
that if there were inflation it would
cause different people to suffer this
someone on either side who will lose I
can't believe that she's this whole idea
that some people are Hawks and some
people are doves that probably applies
to
auditions but not too real intellectuals
okay so I'm going to go for no more than
another half hour and ask for questions
because I'm hoping that I'm striking a
chord here on deep values and important
issues and leave time for some question
but the golden rule and the idea of a
good society are very old but I think
where something is changing that in some
ways seems to be moving away from that
and that is the development of financial
capitalism which is expanding all over
the world is hardly any place you can go
in the world today that if it even if it
didn't have a stock market 20 years ago
it now has one and now it has a futures
market and they're trading credit
default swaps just about everywhere in
the world and why is that well I think
that there's a general recognition that
finance is a powerful technology that
produces wealth
it gets people conflicting in conflict
with each other but but you know you you
kind of need that as a avenue for
creative destruction as the Joseph
Schumpeter called it where businesses
compete against each other and a few of
them succeed and there has to be an
incentive there actually has to be a
money incentive for people to do
practical work the the good society
motives don't drive you to work really
hard to become a real entrepreneur for
most people so it does appear that we do
have to have a financial incentive we
have financial capitalism which works
well but it's not perfect we have to
keep tinkering with it and making the
system work better and the history of
capitalism is a history of tinkerer
that produced new changes so let me
start with just some examples that you
can read about these in my book the it's
a history of experimentation with new
business arrangements and looking for
some that might work better than other
I'll start with the 1811 New York
corporate law New York State in 1811 the
state legislature in New York passed a
new corporate law which said two very
important things first
almost everybody could incorporate or
for almost any line of business I may be
oversimplifying the law but it used to
be that if you wanted to set up a
corporation you had to go to the
governor and you had to get a special
state you know they had to pass a bill
to create your corporate it's almost
impossible to start a corporation they
made it free for everyone but secondly
and this is also very important they
made it limited liability they said that
if someone Sue's the company they can't
go after the shareholders alright and
this was to free up people to want to
invest in corporate stocks it used to be
before 1811 that you could buy shares in
some company and then the company would
do something bad and they'd come after
you they take your house because you
well they said look you were a part of
this company you were profiting from
this there were a real example it was
the Blue Ridge Turnpike in Massachusetts
they bought land from farmers but they
didn't pay them right away and they were
gonna build a Turnpike and then the
company went bankrupt and they didn't
give the they'd lost the money didn't
give it back to the front
farmers were furious and they sued the
stockholders to try to get the money
back they didn't succeed in that case
but that was a worry so in 1811 and New
York made it limited liability was the
law of the land people said this is
going to be a disaster you're going
all kinds of fly-by-night companies
people can just invest in any company
with no worries right they can just they
don't care I don't need to look at the
company I'm investing in and the critics
were negative but what happened is New
York developed into the nation's
financial center and before long every
state in the Union adopted limited
liability and now every country of the
world does it because it frees people of
fears it was an invention it could have
gone badly as some people predicted well
it does go badly you know some of these
companies are crooked maybe they would
be less they would be more up-and-up if
the stockholders were afraid of being
sued but on the other hand there
wouldn't be any stockholders they
wouldn't start no one it only be family
business so you wouldn't invest in
anything unless you knew it well that's
one example see this is a technological
innovation and it I think of it both as
having a like an abstract economic
theory behind it but also a element of
psychology behind it about what drives
people there's a whole revolution going
on now called behavioral finance in
academia bringing psychology into
finance and now some of our finance
professors are writing papers with our
psychology department professors which I
see is a very healthy thing well maybe I
won't the I was going to mention the
Savings Bank movement in the 19th
century the the founding of the
Securities and Exchange Commission in
1934 which created federal regulation to
make your investing safer the investment
company Act of 1940 which created mutual
funds effectively
well maybe I'll mention the dodd-frank
Act of 2010 which created the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau so we have
all kinds of new advances that are going
on and I think that we need our
education has to develop in our students
Minds the importance of all of these
innovations many of the innovations are
regulatory one thing I try to put out of
mine
of our student is the idea that
regulators are kind of second-tier in
finance I think their first tier because
they're the ones who are developing the
rules of the game and we need good rules
of the game otherwise there will be
dangerous play and some people will get
hurt so that's what we're trying to do I
think I think it's a worthy intellectual
exercise that we more than an exercise
it's very important so that's how I see
what I've been doing and teaching
financial markets it's not about making
money it's about getting things
organized to produce all the things that
we need alright you know our medicine or
food or clothes or housing or
transportation all these things have to
be financed alright next I wanted to
talk about business education at Yale
and and more generally in all the
universities but let's look back at what
what do you think you got in a college
education at Yale in the early 19th
century okay I can tell you freshman
year
by the way everyone took the same
courses pretty much freshman year this
is what you got livvie Horace Homer
Euclid sophomore year Cicero and
Xenophon junior year Aeschylus Plato
Thucydides demosthenes but the senior
year you got philosophers of the
Scottish enlightenment so there were
some modern people as well they also
added we had chemistry we had geology in
the early 19th century there was some of
that and there was even some economics I
went back and looked at the economics
textbook written by Francis Weiland in
which we were assigning to all Yale
students around 1840 he was the
president of Brown University
he wrote a textbook of economics it's
still here in the library you can read
it I'm pretty good I think I actually
liked it much more moralizing than our
textbook it kept coming back to the
theme of industry and hard work and
we're not as moralizing now the first
Business School attached to a university
was not at 10 not at Yale I was at Penn
it was the Wharton School founded in
1881 before that there were no business
schools attached to university there
were separate business schools and they
were low prestige they were places where
you learned accounting or stenography
and and they didn't have any pretensions
they they were just teaching business
skills 1881 was a major turning point in
the world the university history because
it created the idea that that a business
education should be part of a university
Josef Wharton said I want to measure the
outcome by how much money the students
can make because I'm a businessman
if the student has if there's a high
demand for the students skill it ought
to be it ought to be expressed well he
was missing something that Adam Smith
called the paradox of value Adam Smith
noted that diamonds sell for a lot and
water for very little but which one is
more valuable that goes back a hundred
years earlier in 1890 there was an
interesting newspaper article where
university presidents were asked to
comment on the Wharton School and that
that at that time was the only Business
School and I thought it was kind of
interesting that these university
presidents were so open to criticize the
Wharton School particularly I have here
a quote from Francis Amasa Walker who by
the way was a Yale economics but or
political economy professor but he had
just been raided away from Yale to
become president of MIT so he's speaking
here as the president of MIT so his
reaction to the Wharton School I'm
quoting him I exceeding
dislike to see the question of college
education put upon such low ground a
young man who would allow his decision
between going to college are staying
away to be determined wholly or mainly
by the prospect of pecuniary return is
unworthy of the benefit of a liberal
education so it was a long time before
there was a second Business School and
it wasn't until the early 1950s when the
first business school as attached to a
university appeared outside of the
United States in Canada so the Yale
stock founded its business school
it didn't call it a business school
originally management management is
different from business right the Yale
University created the School of
Management in 1976 and sorry that wasn't
what they called it it was called the
school of organization and management
and John Perry Miller who was the I
think the Provost of Yale at the time
wrote a book afterwards about the
tribulations he'd gone through to try to
get this through he believed that we
needed a management school he wrote
about it in his book called creating
academic settings and he found that
there was immense opposition to the Yale
from the Yale community to creating a
management school so he told them what
will create a different kind of this
isn't a business school this is a
management and he said it's going to be
more likely isn't that a suitable
studying human organizations how people
work together as an intellectual
discipline isn't that worthy of Yale and
so he got it through but they had to
have it this funny named school of
organization and management or som and
the degree they offered was called
masters of public and private management
public first okay and they said we want
idealistic people who might want to work
for
a non-profit like a museum or a hospital
or they might want to work for the
government as well as business people so
that's what started out now that the
problem was it didn't quite evolve along
quite such lines because it's in it's
difficult to maintain this kind of
uniqueness and so they eventually caved
then and change the name of the degree
to Masters of Business Administration
and they dropped organization from the
school name but they kept calling it's
som now they o stands for of in School
of Management but I still call it som
and in my mind it's still the school of
organization and management because
those values do live on I think Yale is
a unique place in values and the School
of Management is a special business
school that I think still does attract
people who are interested in working for
society and this is something that we
have to keep I've talked to Ted Snyder
the new Dean and I think he is committed
to keeping this uniqueness of our school
it's different than his prior he was at
Chicago a business school they have kind
of a different milieu or a different
culture than we do but it's a wonderful
school there's obviously a wonderful
school but a different social culture I
tell my finance students that I think
that they might make a lot of money our
students are very popular on Wall Street
they do well and some of them make tons
of money I tell my students that they
should be thinking now about giving it
away and I also tell them that they a
little bit about how you can do this
way that's meaningful to you it's part
of my instruction to undergraduates and
final it's a little premature I tell
them about how to set up a family
foundation okay this is what you do
you're working hard making millions of
dollars and you're really not selfish
you're just into this you're having fun
doing this and the government is taxing
it heavily you think well maybe I should
give it away now so I can get a
deduction and not pay all these taxes
well I tell them first of all well
paying taxes isn't a bad thing you're
contributing to society but if it
bothers you you can set up a Family
Foundation now and get a tax-deductible
contribution to your own foundation
and then you can keep the bulk of it
until later when you have time to think
about what you want to do and so that's
but the the first thing is to have a
commitment to philanthropy and I don't
think they expected to get that in a
financial markets course yeah College or
Yale University is I believe more
attuned to that than many universities
one little piece of evidence is a sort
of Galle tradition that we do not name
our colleges after donors we named them
after worthy people this came up well
they may have come I should I didn't say
that right they got you laughing I
didn't say that at all right they may
also be financial people but it's not
the dollars that determines your status
as a it's not just the dollars we have
twelve residential colleges at Yale
University and I thought I would just
tell you who they're named after to
remind you of how the values have guided
us in there we're getting to more now
and they haven't been named yet but we
have Branford College it's named after
the city of Brantford it's our neighbors
sounds neighborly
Calhoun College named after John C
Calhoun vice president of the Unites
States he's controversial for other
things but I'm not gonna mention them at
the moment but certainly a distinguished
person not a wealthy donor John Audubon
Park college named after John Davenport
founder of New Haven colony in the 1600s
Stiles college named after Ezra Stiles a
Congregationalist minister and president
of Yale who by the way when he became
president freed his slave in a moment of
joy that used to have slavery in
Connecticut and and then he'd be way the
stories are all a little bit more
complicated I said I wasn't going to
tell you John Calhoun's downside either
but these were good people in their day
and remarkable people Jonathan Edwards
was a preacher this is controversial too
he started the so-called Great Awakening
which is a huge revivalist movement he
was a class of 1720 at Yale and
extremely influential person who later
became president of Princeton University
Morse College named after Samuel Morse
the inventor of the Telegraph Pearson
college named after
abran Abraham Pearson class of 16 68
from Harvard and the first director of
the Yale University Saybrook College
named after Old Saybrook Connecticut
another tip our hat to one of our
neighbors another town silliman college
named after a Benjamin Silliman Yale
professor and chemists and I seen their
loss Oh Timothy Dwight College there
were two Yale presidents both named
Timothy Dwight the first one 1795 to
1817 and the second one his grandson
1886 to 1898 that was and then Trumbull
College Jonathan Trumbull Harvard again
1727 class and but he was governor of
Connecticut so so who were your the name
our next College well we've raised a
large amount of the money from Charlie
Johnson we yeah I just got a two hundred
and fifty million dollar
and so what did Charlie Johnston's claim
to fame well there may be many of them
but most prominent is that he ran the
Franklin Templeton funds of mutual funds
so Charlie Johnson just gave 250 million
knowing that the college would not be
named after him I think it's an
interesting point actually the Franklin
Templeton father where well it started
out as Franklin funds were founded by
his father and he didn't name it the
Johnson funds it was his own fund he
named his funds after Benjamin Franklin
it's like what Yale does so maybe
Charlie Johnson I think went to Yale and
so those are our values
Ned Evans just gave 50 million dollars
to Yale for the new school of management
building we're going to call that Edward
Evans Hall but we're not going to rename
the business school it's still just the
School of Management so what we have our
people who are coming forth with huge
huge gifts and they're not they don't
seem to be egotist to the extent that
you might think so what do we make of
this it doesn't seem right you know the
people that we value most are not
usually the richest people in society
you might value they might have
wonderful careers too but it's not all
about money right but I think that you
know making tens of millions of dollars
and giving that to your alma mater that
is a good thing to do my young people
aspire to it and I think there's nothing
wrong I think that's great that we name
something after I was just for the last
three days I've been at Princeton
University I was invited to give the
Princeton lectures in finance so I was
lecturing for three days there and I
said to them I noticed when I was
walking across campus that some students
were wearing sweatshirts that said
Whitman College and I said that's
wonderful you've named a college after a
poet Walt Whitman that's what I thought
because Walt Whitman lived in New
Jersey's to be perfect for them to name
their college after such a really deep
and important poet but no it wasn't and
it was named after meg Whitman who is
the founder of eBay the online auction
service so I thought I felt a little
disappointed they didn't have a college
named after a poet but then again I have
to say and they and Princeton doesn't
have Yale's tradition against naming
colleges after donors but on the other
hand I think it's ok I think that we
need a woman our colloquy they're all
male so far and Meg Whitman is a is a
real contributor to our society so I
think I'll give my approval to Whitman
College it's none of my business they're
not at Princeton but the only thing is I
think that it's it's good but I think
that names of colleges should be
dispersed across people that we value
and admire and that it's a worthy
aspiration for young people to aspire to
do that to make money and return it to
their alma mater but it has to be held
delicately I'll give you an example of a
Miss named institution and in 2011 just
two years ago the Miami Art Museum
announced that they were going to rename
the art museum the Jorge M Perez Art
Museum of miami-dade County in
recognition of a donor who was a who is
a real estate developer in Florida who
gave 35 million to the museum in the
form of his personal collection of Latin
American art and some other money as
well now a storm of protests followed
because the the museum had just finished
a 220 million dollar capital campaign
attracting donations from numerous small
donors that's like eight times as big
because mr. Peres
and and that was in the state I think
they you have to have recognition that's
what I like our having Branford and
saber College you know there's different
ways of contributing and it shouldn't be
it has to be handled handled well so let
me just say a few more things about
values at Yale and then I'll open this
up to questions
in 1951 William F Buckley published his
book you know what I'm referring to God
and man at Yale and it's it's he's Roman
Catholic and it's his lament over the
gradual decline of religious values at
the university I this book was highly
influential oh by the way the the
epigraph for the book at the very
beginning of the book it says on a
single page for God for country and for
Yale in that order so well you wouldn't
think this was a successful book because
any book about one University you know
one outside the university is going to
want to read it well it was practically
a best-seller I tried to find out if it
was on the New York Times bestseller
list and I didn't find a way to search
this completely but I think it was not
it didn't make the New York Times
bestseller list but I think it was more
influential than any book on the
bestseller list I looked at the the top
books on the bestseller list in 1951
Rachel Carson the see around us
Thor Heyerdahl kontiki okay so people
wanted to read nice books about beauty
of the ocean and maybe yeah that's a
good book I'm sure
about it and anyone read this so Hydra
dollars an adventurous story they're not
gonna buy a book about Yale right if you
do if he didn't come from you on the
other hand the book had tremendous
significance because it attracted all
kinds of reviews and attention and it
led to what he really wasn't writing
about Yale he was writing about values
and he thought that a university should
express a religion that's a pretty
controversial position already by 1951
and it led to his founding a journal
called National Review in 1953 it just
thrust him onto the world stage and then
he had a television show anyone remember
that called firing line for about 15
years
he was this conservative speaker but by
the way it was published by Yale
University Press which is something we
ought not to remember it's also part of
the Yale community Yale Press is very
good at publishing influential books
books that matter and I've warned you
against being influenced by bestseller
lists I think it's crazy to value
best-selling books especially highly if
you look at what Yale press publishes
there's so many magnificent books and
the the press has such a sense of values
and importance these books will never be
bestseller but that you know even the
bestseller list the way they're
structured they're structured as they
have a weekly cycle on the New York
Times so in order to get on that list
all you have to do is really sell well
for one week so you hire a public
relations expert who knows you know who
knows how will concentrates him and one
week he'll be on for a week his wasn't
that kind of book and yet it led to huge
Changez so well I actually just
mentioned this building we're in right
now but tell chapel is a sign of earlier
values because this building was built
in 1874 it took them two years they
started it in 1874 and they finished it
in 1876 and all Yale students were
required to attend weekly Sunday
services here until 1927
so that was everybody went through this
very scene at Yale I was wondering what
about Jewish students I thought well
maybe they didn't have Jewish students
wrong they did the first Jewish student
to graduate from Yale was 1809 so I I'm
not sure what they did I I think maybe
they just had to do it too so there was
a different but at least it was a
incorporation of our values into our
education we can't go back to that now
we have students from every religious
denomination we can't go back to having
a required service the same for
everybody
so I think I'm about done I'm just going
to say well you know another issue that
really seems important right now in our
society is I mentioned it earlier that
inequality has been getting worse and
I'm worried that it will get even worse
and I think this should be the number
one problem that that we talked about
unfortunately it isn't and it's it seems
to be impossible for most people to talk
about it I've written about this in
various ways but let me just emphasize
that the the principle of openness and
communication that president salary has
expressed seems to me to be related in
my mind with creating an open society
the problem with inequality gets the
worst if there's a clique if there is a
certain subgroup that gets control and
then are loyal to each other there is
that cliquish nish in Wall Street in
finance and that's something that I
think we have to abour so Yael is
increasingly an open community where
people of all religions can come where
people of all races and sexes there's
only well maybe there's more than two
sexes now in some sense I hope that our
next residential college one of them
will be named after a woman finally to
break the 100% nail but that's just a
matter of symbolism the important thing
is I think that our education here at
Yale and I'm hopeful that it will it
will continue as as a free and open
experience that encourages people to
value their participation in a good
society I'll stop for questions do you
have a mic there ism or you can come up
here if you
the basking in reflected yes oh yeah
that's right she was on the Yale
corporation right you know good good
point this reminds me of a famous quote
from the Harvard psychologist William
James who flourished around late 19th
early 20th century and he said a man
will call his all that he can possibly
imagine did I say that I didn't say that
exactly right but it's in the basic
human psychology that you enjoy the
successes of anyone related to you in
any way that you can make so Janet is a
Yale alumnus so we all feel naturally in
heartened by that but I also know her
because I very well because I'm writing
a book with her husband George Akerlof
but also I've just known her as if in
the profession I admired her I know that
counts I feel bad for Larry Summers who
I also know and I think he's gotten an
excessively bad rap he is not against
women I I don't believe
but he anyway it's working out very well
I think she hasn't gotten her
confirmation yet and there's there's a
whole army of people out I think it's
very difficult for her right now you can
imagine what it's like when you have an
army of people trying to destroy your
reputation
right right right yeah well your your
expressing a very fundamental dilemma
that people face in modern financial
capitalism that the people we love the
most may be our teachers our nurses our
daycare operators but we have other job
we can't all do the same thing that the
fundamental I guess as an economist I'm
just thinking about equilibrium we can't
all do the same thing so there has to be
places for for both but see when I was
talking about naming of colleges I'm
thinking that it's okay to name a
college after Meg Whitman that's fine as
long as we name the next college after
something you know someone who wasn't we
have to recognize the different ways of
contributing so I mentioned the paradox
of value that Adam Smith talked about
diamonds have a much higher market price
than water but diamonds are practically
useless so but unfortunately they have a
higher market so if someone's offering
to donate diamonds versus water it's
hard to not make a distinction but I
think that the distinction it has to be
made it has to be made sensitively that
there's different kinds of contributions
and that we value all of them that
that's what the reason I mentioned the
miami-dade example was it was exactly
the wrong thing where people had small
gifts had totaled 220 million and then
one person gives thirty five million and
gets credit for the whole thing that is
wrong but the ælis does not seem to be
making that mistake you have a follow-up
question
that's right right and he went to you
and he was an editor at the Yale Daily
News
it's another fine Yale institution I
didn't mention it
okay that's a very complex question how
it sounds like the topic for a PhD
dissertation maybe that's what it is it
doesn't have an easy answer my nice
thought about the long-standing
antipathy to charging of interest in not
just the Islamic religion but as you
point out that Christian religion
relates to some bad things that happen
routinely with the charging of interest
you had Landers who would capture the
penalties were high you could go to
debtors prison so someone could almost
enslave you by getting you to pay more
than you can also lenders often resorted
to very tough tactics to get repaid also
it's just very unpleasant to deal with
the lender at some point you're having
trouble you know you've you've had an
illness in the family you go back to the
lender and say I can't pay and then some
of them are not nice at that moment
because they have to get the money back
because they're in business so it they
end up looking evil so part of this part
of this can be dealt with by very
suitable regulations notably Elizabeth
Warren who is running a campaign for
many years is now a senator from
Massachusetts proposed creating the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau and
they have a hotline get on their website
and and then you could you can enter
complaints about lenders so they're
trying to clean it she wrote some
articles that pointed out the really bad
behavior of some credit card lenders
they would give you these long contract
when you take out a credit card and
buried in the fine print was we can kill
you if you don't pay basically and they
would obscure it in legal language that
you might not even understand but we've
removing ahead on that the other thing I
would point out is that not all lending
is even remotely bad and I'll give you
the example of Muhammad Yunus who won
the Nobel Peace Prize he's he's an
Islamic how is he how does he do it he's
a glamming but somehow he charges
interest on loans in Bangladesh it had
founded a bank called the Grameen Bank
that emphasize giving small loans to
very poor people to start a business
the typical example was a woman in
living in abject poverty all she wants
is to buy one of those little hand carts
with a heating opera so she could go out
on the street and sell meals and make
money for her family that's a very
that's microfinance a very small thing
and banks wouldn't even pay any
attention to these people they're just
too small the expenses exceeded any
possible profit from dealing with them
but unis found a way to make a profit in
other words he was not running a charity
he was running a business and but he was
proselytizing that this is a business
that works so most people think that's
good so I don't see it as can clear
black and white term so we could talk
further about this is there's a lot of
issues hi
yeah well I agree I think that community
is how we divine our lives and it's it's
a mistake that we should be educating
people out of that that business or
money matter more than than they they
seem there's a concern that our society
is losing some of its community so Doug
gray is a professor here at Yale wrote a
book called city which I recommend about
New Haven and he compares New Haven in
1900 with New Haven now and argues that
there were many more civic groups little
bands or choirs and activities and then
there are now this is reflected more on
Robert putnams later book called Bowling
Alone where he claims that walking into
a bowling alley today you see a lot of
people who came all by themselves to the
bowling alley to bowl all alone whereas
they used to come as bowling clubs we
might not think of bowling clubs as
important institutions but maybe they
are and maybe a sense of community is
important one thing I like about Yale is
its arts which are unusually strong and
I'm not I think it's very good that we
subsidize a broad range of intellectual
activity
yeah
income inequality tends to be dealt with
in wartime that's a sad fact in
peacetime no one has the political will
to attack it we got our first income tax
in 1913 just before World War one but it
was tiny tiny tiny tax and they
increased it substantially during World
War one temporarily and why it's because
these men are fighting and dying out
there how can you be making millions of
dollars and just profiting now so
society became more egalitarian it
happened again and they started cutting
taxes after the war and they went up
again after World War two and then they
gradually declined so that's just a sad
fact of nature during war people feel
more committed to each other but we
don't want that happen so we're living
in a world I don't know we need I've
proposed measures that would help one
thing that I've done it since you asked
about this I think there's a
psychologist trope who writes about what
he calls temporal construal theory that
people are more idealistic in the
abstract than in the here-and-now so if
you ask people should we raise taxes on
the rich and and especially if you put
it should we in 50 years from now if
there's a bad inequality should we raise
taxes on the rich
they don't say generously yes but if you
say should we do it right now then they
get queasy people are just genuinely
usually this is the way most people live
their lives they think of themselves as
an idealistic generous person but not
today
I can't feed generous today
so that's what survived proposal in my
book new financial order was that we
should plan now for increasing
inequality and this is my if I were a
law professor I would write draft
legislation for this don't haven't gone
that far but I'm not seeing any interest
in it either but this is still my
campaign let's have a contingency plan
now to raise income taxes in the future
if inequality gets even worse and this
is the other thing we're talking about
inequality today it's trending worse we
don't know how far that's going to go
and there are fears that with the advent
of computers and global economics that
it's going to get more ruthless and more
people will be displaced by computers
and I don't know if that's going to
happen no one knows the future why not
have a plan right now to deal with that
instead we seem to get distracted by all
kinds of little things and never focus
on something like that so I you know I
had some output some people in
Washington said well it could be that
this could be part of a compromise so
say the one side wants say a new
regulation that will boost GDP but it
will make it even more unequal then you
could say alright you can get that but
we've got to put in a contingency plan
to deal with the unnie quality maybe it
could slip through that way maybe if I
were a more ardent campaigner for these
kinds of ideas I could actually make
something like that happen but as it now
it's like global warming nobody's doing
anything about it and nobody's even
hardly even talking about it well if
there's other things that can be dealt
with Jacob hacker here in the political
science department has a book called
winner-take-all politics that with a
Pierson
that that documents the increasing power
of financial lobbying it's gotten a lot
stronger and so maybe we can make some
better lobbying law
help prevent the undue influence of the
financial community on our lawmaking I
think we have time for one this would be
that have to be I think we're running
out of time
one more question that no I like to eat
that's our math professor right nowyou
well we have two more questions you can
go modeling or why am i delighted by
what i do within economics actually I
think I could be in any department of
the university I just like intellectual
I can be in the math oh maybe I couldn't
make it in the past as part of my mind
in terms of likes I'd love to do that
too so it seems to me that yeah it's
just the genuineness of academic
discourse and the I like it all and I
like it especially when I see that it
has a purpose for people and it's how
mr. professor how yes
when you reduce taxes on the rich
that sounds okay another question I
don't know it doesn't ring a bell for an
article that I've read recently but I'm
sure there is that feedback right so it
goes bad at the end too so I keep
thinking people with real emotional
intelligence don't want to be in a
society that's highly unequal it just
doesn't feel good or you know it's
really people don't love you because
you're rich it doesn't I come back to my
state it doesn't matter
but you there's a mistake that people
who are somewhat compromised on their
emotional intelligence will make and
become far too focused on money that's
not what we're about that's not what my
financial markets course is about and
it's not it's not what Yale is about